wirklich schön hier schade dass es mit
dieser idylle bald vorbei ist und alle
hier sterben werden
guten tag mein name ist klar
für scheiße geparkt ja
schlimm maschine aus rollen jetzt ich
sage sie doch schönen guten tag mein
name ist klar das training kommen im
auftrag des bundesamtes für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
katastrophe gutes stichwort ich habe mit
zitronen münchen im herbst keine zeit
sorry
wir führen ab jetzt stichprobenartige
kontrollen zur bevorratung lage unserer
bundes bevölkerung durch sie sind der
erste also ich glaube nicht dass das in
ordnung ist
mit hallo
was geht hier überhaupt warum nichts
besonderes bloß um das nackte überleben
von ihnen und ihrer familie
die gute alte panikmache
panikmache echt jetzt unser
wirtschaftsminister hat gerade die
warnstufe 2 bei der gasversorger
ausgerufen stufe 2 danach kommt nur noch
eine dann hat er es aber armageddon
kennen sie eigentlich unsere broschüre
sie packen jetzt bitte nicht im wachturm
aus das hier ist der ratgeber für
notfallvorsorge und richtiges handeln in
notsituationen
ließ mir auf jeden fall später durch
wenn die apokalyptischen reiter vor der
tür stehen damit das ist ein
einzelexemplar
und wenn sie hier schon so große töne
spucken dann schauen wir doch einfach
mal wie gut sie bevorratet sind an sich
bei uns können sorgen unser keller ist
voll zeigen ist ja so wenig aufgeräumt
egal bitte
ich habe von ihrer komischen broschüre
noch nie was gehört also endlich werden
würden die an alle haushalte verteilt
aber das ist ja auch bullerbü
wir verteilen die auch aber eben
exklusiv über das internet müssen die
deutschen eben ein bisschen mitarbeiten
sehr interessant so kommen wir zum
wesentlichen hier klopapier da bin ich
2020 in fünf verschiedene supermärkte
und hab die eingesammelt aber was soll
ich ihnen sagen bis heute nicht auf
geschissen also
aufgebracht das ist keine vorbereitung
für den ernstfall das ist soziales
hamstern obwohl wenn sie das klopapier
mit dem mehl und der hefe mischen und
ganz kurz darauf stellen dann können sie
aus der masse einer 1a hochwasser mauer
bauen nein
bleiben wir beide doch mal beim äußerst
realistischen szenario dass ihr mit den
vielen gasreserven und den
unzureichenden erneuerbaren energien
ganz bald einen blackout haben werden
ich glaube sie haben ein blackout gerade
ihnen wird das lachen auch noch vergehen
weiter im text haben sie denn batterien
vier stück oben in der fernbedienung
reicht auch oder streichhölzer
teelichter kerzen teelichter ich bin
seit 19 jahren verheiratet da ist die
zwar mit romantik
haben sie eine taschenlampe taschenlampe
ich habe die taschenlampe eine schweizer
armee taschenlampe die schießen mammut
die augen aus ja
kann man auch als als pfefferspray
benutzen so manuell
hier ist die scheiß schweizer
taschenlampe im gegensatz zu ihnen haben
die schweizer 1 ab und unfälle vorräte
was soll das jetzt
[Musik]
willkommen in der hölle sie sind ja noch
gruseliger als meine finanz prüferin
wissen sie eigentlich was in deutschland
los ist wenn es zu einem blackout kommt
zunächst einmal fallen alle ampeln aus
verkehrschaos tausende tote im
straßenverkehr
man kann nur noch mit bargeld zahlen
alle handy akkus sind leer
krankenhäuser altenheime müll und
abwasserentsorgung ohne strom alles am
arsch apropos im arsch
main münchen braucht langsam mal wieder
meine aufmerksamkeit
apropos hühnchen in den deutschen
mastbetrieben sterben ohne belüftung und
futter automatik abermillionen von
schweinen rindern und hühnchen es
kassieren solchen dagegen ist oder nur
ein pickel am aus so sind sie fertig mit
ihrem vortrag bei wie gesagt
sieht man es einfach nicht verstehen
oder
kommen sie mal mit
das sollte jedes verantwortungsvolle
familienoberhaupt für eine familie mit
vier personen im ford haben
100 liter wasser 14 kilo reis kartoffeln
oder nudeln 60 kilo gemüse die viel obst
oder nüsse zehn liter milch und 600 war
und das reicht nur für schlappe zehn
tage okay okay okay aber jetzt sagen sie
mir mal bitte wie soll jemand die meine
putzfrau sich das alles leisten können
bei dem was ich jetzt halt schon mal was
von darwin gehört natürliche selektion
bei ihnen scheint das problem allerdings
eher
kognitiv zu sein
dumme frage
war ein blackout wie wollen sie diese
dose erwärmen nimmt sie scheinen hier
nicht mal ein campingkocher zu haben
nicht schlecht campingkocher er zeigt
ich immer ja die profis machen kommen
sie mit
schauen sie mal
schon mal was von dem smoker gehört
nichts gase oder irgendwie elektro oder
so holz holz dh zur not fahre ich
einfach mal eine holzterrasse oder ein
gartenzaun die schuhe meiner frau oder
was weiß ich meine schwiegermutter aber
ich und meine familie
wir sind safe dann zeigen sie mal okay
kein problem
gut also bei 40 grad niedriger
temperatur das kann jetzt natürlich ein
bisschen dauern also lange zeit sind sie
wahnsinnig kommen sie das wollen wir
noch brauchen verbieten oder gelungen
ist mir scheißegal aber dass das ist ein
vortrag mit mitgas ist beschlagnahmt das
gehört ab sofort zur gas notreserve der
bundesrepublik deutschland so jetzt mal
unter uns sie dennoch wahrscheinlich
gesponsert hier vom supermarkt oder so
damit wir bürger uns und das ganze zeug
alles kaufen oder nicht ganze großstadt
ich versuche sie hier gerade auf den
notfall vorzubereiten aber sie sie
können die wahrheit doch gar nicht
vertragen warum auch mal einfach so
weitermachen kann wie bisher seien die
hast du scheiße union
[Musik]
gar nicht schön
und wir sehen wollen wie man selber dem
atomkrieg überleben abonnieren sie den
kanal das wird ja nur um leben und tod
und nur ein hühnchen